e
métro de Montréal. Comme nous le
dit Marie-Josée Paquette
comment.
- ♪ Pa pa pa pa pa pa pa ♪
Habituellement, je la siffle,
mais c'est dur avec le masque.
- Ce n'est pas le port du masque
obligatoire qui empêchera Daniel
de jouer dans le métro.
DANIEL LALONDE, musicien
dans le métro dee métro dee mét0
- Ça fait du bien,
on dirait qu'il y a une vie
qui recommence.
♪ ♪ ♪
- À partir d'aujourd'hui,
accueille de nouveau
les musiciens dans ses couloirs.
"Je suis heureux d'être
de retour, dit ce guitariste.
C'est ainsi que je gagne
un peu d'argent l'hiver venu.
Pour commencer, trois stations
de métro accepterons
les artistes : Berri-UQAM,
Guy-Concordia et Jean-Talon.
♪ ♪ ♪
La réservation des emplacements
se fera maintenant en ligne.
PHILIPPE DÉRY, Société
de transport de Montréal
- On estime qu'il y a environ
200 musiciens qui pouvaient
faire des perfordes perfordes ps
dans le métro avant la pandémie.
À l'heure actuelle, on a déjà
une soixantaine de musiciens
qui sont inscrits.
- ♪ Hey ♪- Des artistes visiblet
appréciés des passants.
- Moi, je suis content, ça fait
de l'ambiance, et je trouve
qu'il y a de bons musiciens.
- Je suis super content, ça met
de la joie dans mon coeur,
c'est parfait.
- Bien moi, ça me donne
envie de danser.
- Et elle n'est visiblement
pas seule.
- ♪ Demain peut-être
ou même ce soir ♪
♪ On va se dire... ♪
Les gens passent et tu vois
qu'ils sont contents de nous
revoir. Mais ils ont des
masques, hein! C'est pas facile
à voir. Mais il y en a beaucoup
qui font ça de même, "Yeah!",
en voulant dire : "C'est cool
de te revoir! Yes, sir!"
Ça fait plais
♪ ♪ ♪
- La STM a retrouvé plus
de la moitié de sa clientèle
depuis le début de la pandémie.
- On espere que le retour
des musiciens contribuera aussi
à convaincre d'autres clients
d'être de ret
notre réseau eux aussi.
- Ici Marie-Joseé Paquette-
Comeau, Radio-Canada, Montreal.
- ♪ Paaa ♪
♪ ♪ ♪